[Music]
the finish lines in sight and you put on
an extra burst of speed as your legs
pick up the pace your breathing gets
deeper your heart pounds faster and
sweat pours over your skin how does this
substance suddenly materialize and what
exactly is its purpose there are a
number of scenarios that can make us
sweat eating spicy foods nervousness and
when we're sick but exercise is probably
the most familiar and common in that
case sweating happens as a response to
movement triggered deep inside your
cells as you increase your pace your
muscles work harder increasing their
demand for energy a process called
cellular respiration consumes glucose
and oxygen to form ATP the energy
currency of the cell much of this
process takes place in structures called
mitochondria the more you move the
harder mitochondria work to supply your
body with energy all this work comes at
a cost though as the cells break down
the ATP they release heat the heat
stimulates temperature sensors
throughout your body those receptors
detect the excess heat being produced by
your muscle cells and communicate that
information to the hypothalamus which
regulates body temperature the
hypothalamus responds by sending signals
out through the sympathetic nervous
system to the sweat glands in your skin
these are distributed all over the body
with especially high concentrations on
the palms of your hands the soles of
your feet and on your head when a sweat
gland first receives the signal the
fluids surrounding the cells in it's
coiled base contains high amounts of
sodium and chloride the cells pump these
ions into a hollow tube that runs
through the sweat gland then because
it's saltier inside the tube then
outside water moves into the tube by
osmosis as what's called the primary
secretion builds up in the bottom of the
tube
water pressure pushes it up into the
long straight part of the duct before it
seeps onto the skin cells lining the
tube will reclaim as much salt as
possible so the process can continue the
water in sweat absorbs your body's heat
energy and then evaporates off of you
when it reaches the surface which in
turn lowers your temperature this
process known as evaporative cooling was
an important adaptation for our
ancestors this cooling effect isn't only
helpful during exercise we sweat in many
other scenarios to eating particularly
spicy food makes some people sweat
profusely from their faces that happens
because spices trigger the same neural
response in the brain that activates
temperature receptors which usually
respond to increased heat sweating is
also part of the fight-or-flight
response
stimulated by stressful scenarios like
asking someone on a date or interviewing
for a job this happens because
adrenaline stimulates muscle activity
and causes blood vessels to widen to
responses that increase heat and trigger
the sweating response and sweating also
occurs when we get sick when we're
feverish we sweat because infections
stimulate the hypothalamus to increase
muscle activity which in turn releases
more energy as heat that increases your
overall temperature a protective
mechanism that makes your body less
habitable for infectious agents like
with running sweating helps your body
vent that heat when the fever is over or
you've won your race your temperature
receptors sense the decrease in heat and
the hypothalamus brings your sweating
response to an end in some cases like
after a run the hypothalamus also
signals to your body that you need to
replenish the water that you've used out
so when you're pushing yourself to reach
that next goal you can think of sweat as
your body's very own calibrator enabling
you to go that extra mile
have you given the ted-ed newsletter a
try if not don't sweat it click here to
sign up and receive the week's most
unmissable videos blog posts and more
delivered to your inbox once a week
[Music]